okay everyone recently someone rieta did
Star Wars the last Jedi into a 46
minutes recut that's causing a bit of
controversy this anonymous editor in
troll removed massive sections of the
film including cutting out a lot of the
female characters calling it his de
femme Anais fan edit he also removed a
and reorder at a ton of sequences that
justice recut totally incomprehensible
it's hard to see how this person even
considered himself a fan at all
director Rian Johnson and several of the
film's cast members simply responded by
deleting endless laughter and laughs
emojis which is probably the best way to
respond to this guy's because clearly
this editor is just a troll trying to
rile people up thank you for saying that
because that needs to be put out there
this dudes just doing it so that we talk
about him right he's just once a rise
out of people I don't do you believe
that he actually like no yeah okay I
think I think on some level he has to
love Star Wars in order to spend the
time to read it very protective it
sounds like it's an ownership this is my
Star Wars and you do my Star Wars how I
would have done it so I'm gonna do it
now yeah I'm gonna do it and rather than
just show it my friends I'm going to
release it out there just to see how
people react and what headlines I'll get
um think peace blog it would have taken
a lot of time and effort so to defend
all that time and just show his friends
what a ways well having watched it
unfortunately I did I sped through parts
of it but I can honestly tell you there
was just a huge waste of 46 minutes guys
it just made the last Jedi worry
whatever you didn't like about the last
Jedi it just made it worse and it ruined
things he did like about it but I
thought I'd jump on this grenade for
everyone and explain what the big
changes were some of which are just
laughably weird and I'm gonna go they're
just my top 5 most ridiculous ones okay
in the scene where kylo and Leia connect
via the force during the battle and kylo
decides to hold off and this recut Kiley
just immediately blasts the bridge and
killed his mom doesn't me think about
and in this version this actually kills
Leia there's a long shot of her frozen
face I guess it's a tribute to Carrie
Fisher the movie so Carrie Fisher is not
a woman yeah she's just a an object that
you want to just stare at I don't know
if so really good
okay also strangely raised cave mirror
scene was left in in its entirety but
her forced
timing with kylo was cut a
with Luke and Kalos conflicting accounts
of what went down between them and the
whole Yoda scene all cut so Yoda is
actually a woman all right no one's been
able to say otherwise wasn't there a
female Yoda at all free cool yeah on the
other Jedi Council yes there was
I know that I I just don't get why you
would keep some of this weird mythology
stuff but then you'd be annoyed by some
of it to not get it's just all over the
place in terms of what this guy's agenda
was okay all the stuff on can't I bite
and Laura Dern's character hold oh were
removed don't hate I get where he's
coming on some of that but this Joker
made it look like Poe Dameron was the
one who kamikaze the radisson to the
supremacy even though in this cut Poe
Dameron shows up later in the Battle of
Crete that is logic trying to use how
dare you it was ridiculous so he just
took shots of Poe in like the pilot's
seat and then like a wide shot of it you
know hyper hyper speeding into the end
of the supremacy and then like later
poacher shows up no questions doesn't
make sense now when Kyle oh yeah he's
but he's got a new Jedi pal which made
him materialize in the flesh and really
be that yeah well maybe he just chucked
the Luke we don't know when kylo skewers
Snoke this is my favorite when he kills
snook with a lightsaber this guy did
some really goofy effect to make Snoke
fade away like cross-dissolve with
really bad repurposed audio Snoke sane
and laughing what happened why chop them
fighting you see like Snoke severed
corpse there but I guess he liked
obi-wan dawei from it I don't really
know what he was going and then finally
Luke's appearance on crate at the end
isn't force projection in this re-edit
it's actually Luke there's no layering
in because remember she's dead Luke just
shows up winking at Threepio and then
walks out to face the first order the
walkers fire on him and then immediately
dies there's no battle with kylo that's
the movie pretty much ends
yeah so that's why I think this is kind
of a troll and guys there are a lot of
ways to talk about it I kind of only
give this guy the pleasure of being
offended politically which is probably
what he wants on some level but I do
think this brings up an interesting
conversation about fan edits in general
this isn't the first time someone has
rieta dat Star Wars movies trying to
like fix perceived shortcomings in 2012
Topher Grace the actor edited the
prequels into one 85 minute movie that
he showed the friends at a private
screening and they also do is pretty
good it begins with the Darth Maul duel
from Phantom Menace and the mostly
statistics to Anakin's journey to become
vader after that leaving out the Trade
Federation clone war political stuff I
have to agree with his editor it's so
well done we never needed a
nine-year-old anni we didn't write that
whole exposition it could have been done
in a shot and then boom straight to the
good juicy stuff yeah I mean as a screen
art of myself I kind of just want to let
the creator's work stand on its own like
whether I like it or not like who knows
how her attitudes will change over the
years right like I know I've enjoyed
Revenge of the Sith more and more over
the years after initially like kind of
you know have you really watched it you
just thought everybody watched a couple
times and I'm like you know what that
there's parts of this that are way
better than parts of Return of the Jedi
I know yes right Ewan McGregor's great
now the department's great the writings
a little goofy but the directing of the
actors is a little goofy but anyway I
want to know what you guys think like is
that ever justified to create a fan edit
of Star Wars movies or any movie for
that matter I mean when it comes to
justified
it's just fans in most cases celebrating
something
yeah in other cases they think that they
can fix it this what we've been talking
about for the majority of this
conversation is clearly done just to be
troll and if you want to do that that's
fine because sometimes that's the
funniest like I saw a fan edit of Harry
Potter where it's on it's on the it's on
the train in the first movie and his
glasses are broken and her mind he's
gonna be like oh I know it's but I can
fix that Ivana Cadabra and then credits
roll I think there's there's there's a
that it just depends yep a parody or a
joker
yeah there's a rillette of a scene in
the Deathly Hallows by the movie where
like Voldemort has that weird
of like Oh looky this was just hugging
him oh he's got to drag his parents no
there's I think it's there's a time to
place and I think the most exciting part
is when there's like a celebration of it
there's plenty of fan edits of trailers
out there where they're like oh I made
Christ as a DC versus Marvel and I
always watch them I'm like you know what
overall like you guys took the time to
sit there and cut out all these
characters in these scenes and put them
together for the most part it works and
I appreciate what you did like it yeah
for the most part it's for the most part
it's harmless I mean I find it's under
the same umbrella as people that want to
sew costumes to replicate a character
those who want to draw fan art you know
it's there it's kind of making content
from an already established piece of
content really but again like all things
on the internet just because you have
freedom of speech doesn't mean it's
freedom to be an [ __ ] yeah good on
him he's that's how he's decided to use
his time yeah and you know I suppose
sometimes a great discussion and usually
in this case just a goddamn eye roll
yeah right like I think if your attitude
going in to do a fan edit is like like
Sam said to celebrate it or yeah to make
a new piece of content that is just
enjoying it great if you're going in to
like fix things it's like there's so
many other things in the world that you
can fix or you can create new content
that that speaks you're horribly cynical
and backwards point of view but anyway
that's just me maybe just do a fan film
Star Wars 360 thank you it's a
celebration of Star Wars original piece
in this there you go that sounds great
you can do something that has like
almost an academic analytical take on it
right like I saw someone put on Vimeo a
rika of the original alien and
Prometheus and Prometheus kind of had
you know some people who weren't crazy
about it but they called it derelict and
they took
pieces of both films they put it all in
black and white it looked gorgeous and
they they used it to tell these parallel
timelines of like Ripley's character and
then the leaf character whose name I
don't remember in and Prometheus they
they ended up like making something new
out of both films and showed how both of
these characters were in similar
situations and it didn't feel like it
was being cynical toward Prometheus it
just showed like hey there are things
about this movie that are still really
good because notice how you loved them
when they're an alien and what if there
was just there's these historical
reverberations in the way that the
arrogance of these scientists and
assuming that they can they're in
control of nature
I loved it they had to take it down
because Warner Brothers like but in that
case I think there are examples if you
really put in the time and you have an
attitude of let's try to like find what
really worked about these and make
something new out of it it's gonna be
great
if you do want a good fam was universe
and to really appreciate the genius
level of vision that George Lucas did
have someone has decided to edit parts
of the original trilogy alongside the
prequels direct sort of parallel in some
particular moments or like reverse but
in a mirror what you know each other
yeah and it made you appreciate this the
prequels a lot more more also just to do
a little plug if I may my my co-host DJ
for only stupid answers he did a pitch
for the prequels in this really cool way
where was like Seven Samurai and obi-wan
and qui-gon or like like higher Jedi
they can come out and like help protect
you and I like had both Jango Fett my
channel it was of his idea for the the
prequels made me excited and wanted me
to go made me want to go watch but I'm
like I'm not gonna see what he just told
me but as a celebration of fan edits and
fan like changes he did a good job so
only Stu manager people go listen to it
so it was a fun episode well let us know
your thoughts about this fan edit in the
comments and tweet us directly and as a
reminder just follow and subscribe to
new rock stories for more in depth
breakdowns in and out
starwars thanks everybody